[Music]
taylor's in fort worth texas hey taylor
what's up
how are you doing sarah i'm doing well
good how can we help
yes sir so my wife and i have about 170
000 in student loan debt
and we are considering moving about five
hours away for another job
um to try to uh
get more
intense of getting out of this debt and
i just wanted to know your opinion on if
it would be a wise decision or not
so what are these jobs what are you
moving from and two
um i would be moving from where i am now
to doing the same job
i'm a nurse anesthetist
and
i'll be doing the exact same job just a
different location so what were you
making and what will you be making
um it's about i was making 150 and just
the base rays would be
about 190 with the potential to go up to
about 290
depending on how much overtime i'd like
to work wow there's a lot of upside here
and as far as moving are you're married
yeah okay and how does your wife feel
about this
the move um so we have a four-month-old
she's currently staying home with her
right now and
she's just willing to do whatever for us
to
just tackle this debt and get out of
debt even sooner so that we can
um you know eventually get into a house
and start saving for retirement and all
the
sequential steps of the baby steps
you're asking the question of whether
you should move why would you not do
this
well the the pros definitely are
the the pay raise um
and you know the dfw area is a good
place to be and
another pro is that we do have some
family over there that would help
um the con would obviously just be
packing everything up and moving um i'm
also uh in the reserves and i also
have a drill here once a month
um so that would just be another little
roadblock
and those are kind of the things that
are holding me up
you're moving to dfw
i thought you were in fort worth
yes sir i'm in fort worth we would be
moving five hours away in another city
in texas where
uh lubbock
okay
all right so lubbock pays
hundred thousand dollars a year more
than you're making now in dfw
for nurse anesthetist
if i did um some overtime
i could potentially exceed greater than
100.
why does lubbock pay a hundred thousand
dollars more than dfw that's not logical
they are um
they sort staffed and get desperate for
help
yes sir and bfw is very attractive for
families and people wanting to move here
so
the the supply for people wanting to be
here is a lot greater than the demand
logical okay
so the the downside is just packing up
and moving no one likes doing that but
there's not a lot of downside it sounds
like you said you have family in lubbock
are you saying you have a family in fort
worth
uh so i have one family member here in
fort worth um and my wife's majority of
her family are in lubbock okay
it sounds like i'm doing this move
and here's the thing
no one said you had to stay 20 years
go over there for five years get the
mess cleaned up lay yourself a big nest
egg and then decide what you want to do
you may the supply demand curve may
shift again and you may be able to move
into a larger town if you want to move
back to a dfw type situation out of
lubbock if you want a different
lifestyle than small town because
lubbock's obviously a small town
lifestyle
yes sir and so um you know it's how you
want to live i don't care how you want
to live
um i got a buddy of mine from lubbock
and it's so flat there he says you can
watch your dog run away for three days
and so um
you know but the uh
uh you know it's a wonderful town i've
been there a bunch of times but uh so
you just decide what you want to do how
you guys want to live but i don't think
there's anything wrong with at your age
and your stage of career in the first
five years of your child's life being
near the kid's
grandparents and mom her mom and dad and
whatever and that kind of stuff that's
all that's all positives i think it
takes the pressure off of the decision
if you say it might not be permanent
it might be a five-year thing
and then if you choose to stay that's
okay but if you get over there miserable
you can always move because the
beautiful thing about the career field
that you chose is it has a wonderful roi
yeah unlike we were talking about in the
first segment i mean nurse anesthetist
is ding ding do you're the money he can
make
and i'm a little surprised he's not
making better than that at dfw
uh but that's
because it's just a great income
producer man that that one
yeah they make more a lot of docks
so uh
good good good choice but yeah i i don't
you know and here's the other thing i
you could look for yet another option
what's that is there something in dfw
that pays more do you do something maybe
it's just the hospital group you're with
or is there something if you went to
unesco between lubbock and uh in size
and dfw how about san antonio
you know and move down us you know in
between i mean dallas is a major you
know top 20 city san antonio's not yeah
and so you can move maybe maybe there's
a middle ground i don't know but the
good news is family's near i i'm doing
it for a while
i think yeah it's a reversible decision
and i mean he's got a great income
and it's 170k in debt either way you're
gonna pay it off in two years or two and
a half years and so to me is it worth
the move for that now with the upside of
overtime and really stacking up some
money and getting yourself in a great
financial position i'm doing that if it
means driving five hours and packing up
my stuff and the baby yeah packing up
your stuff's not a thing man you ain't
got that much stuff